It's really weird because I write for,
it's this high culture magazine in all
of my great original influences.
I like low culture.
I mean,
I,
I love Fitzgerald.
I love,
love,
love fits.
Joe,
you know,
I,
I love the New Yorker.
Um,
I love all these high culture things,
but the first things that taught me
about how words were beautiful,
it was like hip hop and dungeons and
dragons and I can't remember a taking
dungeons and dragons has all these.
I'm about to get real nerdy on you.
I hope you're ready for this.
They're using dragon says all these,
these great books.
Okay.
And so like I can remember taking one of
the books is the monsters,
man.
You went into the list of all these
mythological monsters that inhabit a
world of Greyhawk,
of dungeons and dragons.
And I can remember just sitting back and
flipping through and looking at the
words and the descriptions and,
and it would come alive for me.
And that was a beautiful thing.
I was the first lesson for me
about how words can take you somewhere
else and a hip hop was the first lesson
in terms of how words are beautiful.
Um,
my parents were very much in the books
and so I,
I read a lot,
certainly as a kid,
um,
but in terms of people talking in the
language,
the kids speak in a,
someone speaking in the slang of my
generation,
um,
when I heard something like a rock him
follow the leader,
he says I could take a phrase that's
rarely heard,
flip it,
and now it's a daily word.
And that was like,
hi,
cool.
For me,
that was beautiful.
That was beautiful.
And I desperately wanted to do something
that beautiful.
Um,
and it wasn't the sort of thing that you
thought it was beautiful because someone
told you it was beautiful,
you felt it.
It was a feeling like here.
Uh,
and of course all your friends,
a lot of your friends felt it too.
But
a lot of things later I,
I had to learn.
So I later in college I studied poetry,
which is also a huge influence on me.
But I had to learn why poetry was
beautiful.
Um,
I really did.
I had to learn why art was beautiful.
Um,
I had to learn why certain music was
beautiful.
Um,
and that,
and that's true for certain aspects of
hip hop,
but a,
for a lot of it,
it touched on such a visceral level.
I desperately wanted to create something
that did that.
Still do.